zum elften juli bis 31
dezember 1967 hütet das österreichische
bundesheer den ersten hochalpinen
assistenzeinsatz in der geschichte der
zweiten republik durch der politische
rahmen war die sogenannte südtirol frage
gewesen
südtirol sollte nach ende des zweiten
weltkriegs italien verbleiben um die
rechte der südtiroler entsprechend zu
schützen wurde ein autonomie paket
geschnürt genannte sogenannte gruber de
gasperi abkommen mit der umsetzung
seitens der italienischen regierung war
man eher in südtirol nicht besonders
zufrieden
man fürchtete eine weiterführung der
italiens politik aus der
zwischenkriegszeit mit der wieder lang
der österreichischen souveränität 1955
versuchte wien jetzt stärker
diplomatischen druck in der autonomie
frage sie tools auszuüben
man erreichte sogar eine eigene
un-resolution im jahr 1960
dennoch waren diese bestrebungen fast
vergebens
nicht zuletzt deshalb schlossen sich
zahlreiche radikalere kräfte in südtirol
in den 1950 er jahren zum sogenannten
befreiungs ausschuss südtirol zusammen
um über gewaltaktionen auf ihre probleme
aufmerksam zu machen
die aktivitäten des befreiungs
ausschusses aber auch die italienischen
gegenmaßnahmen führten ab 1960 er jahren
zu einer eskalation der gewalt auf
beiden seiten
letztendlich waren 14 todesopfer zu
beklagen
der anschlag auf der prozess hat den 25
1967 mit vier todesopfern
für die zu einer weiteren eskalation
italien begann die österreichische
verhandlungen zum beitritt zur
europäischen wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
beziehungsweise europäischen
gemeinschaft für kohle und stahl zu
blockieren und forderte er energische
gegenmaßnahmen
daraufhin wurde der assistenzeinsatz des
österreichischen bundesheeres angeordnet
11 167 war ein klassischer
assistenzeinsatz gemäss bundesverfassung
von der österreichischen bundesregierung
angeordnet vom innenministerium
angefordert die kernaufgaben waren sehr
klar vom reschenpass bis zum laser stahl
in osttirol die grüne grenze zu
überwachen die illegale grenzübertritte
zu verhindern
insgesamt befanden sich von juli bis
dezember 1967 5000 soldaten hier im
einsatz die längste verweildauer für den
einzelnen soldaten lag bei circa sechs
wochen
es waren sowohl verbände aus west
österreich als auch verbände aus
ostösterreich im einsatz
die weste österreichischen verbände
gebirgs upload gebirgs erfahren
der einsatz war die hochgebirgs gelände
die verbände aus österreich in ihren in
ihren garnisonen vorbereitet durch
bergführer und bekamen hier auch
bergführer seine berater innen zu
bedenken die unterbringung im
einsatzraum gestaltete sich anfangs
überaus schwierig es werden zeltlager
errichtet und in weiterer folge
provisorische unterkünfte die größten
probleme ergaben sich allerdings im
bereich der fernmelde ausrüstung
zahlreiche patronen und status hat die
teilweise tagelang keine verbindung
zur versorgung der truppen in ihren oft
sehr exponierten lagen gelangten so
wolle die staffeln aber auch
geländewagen vom typ buch haflinger zum
einsatz
das moderne die panther im
österreichischen bundesheer ist
heutzutage das sogenannte
doch wie groß sind eigentlich die
unterschiede der damaligen ausrüstungen
des gebirgs kämpfers zu heutigen die
ausrüstung eines frühen sorten zu einem
heutigen zu lauten sigma mischung
wirklich andere fahrer
und was heißt das gravierendste war
früher aber hat meistens soll es
schwerer
man sieht es schon an der rose die waffe
einmal länger schwerer basierter stockes
kaliber kopp heutige woche kurz vieles
aus plastik das heißt wo steht nicht
wird leicht zum reining aber sehr viel
munition
man sieht nicht nur die magazine wie bei
uns waren es heißen sondern dem magazine
dort alles aus plastik daher leicht zu
reinigen leichter und viel viel mehr
munition ein mann aus richtung selber
die uniform ist heute natürlich meistens
als plastik stoffen die leichter brocken
leichter und geringer sein früher
baumwolle schwer zum trocknen aber
trotzdem ohne form war zum kämpfen
dieses prozent zum kämpfen lange man
sicher typische solche helden früherer
helden passform wosnitza super trotzdem
hat aus geschützt heutiger helm super
passform heute mir aus kann geräte
aufnehmen wie als 80 geräte liegt etwa
typisches beispiel ist also der rucksack
und eispickel man sich kais wirklich nur
mal kurz für stein eis zu gehen
früher häufig leer war leider bislang
und zum wirklich für stein eis gehen
also nicht richtig geeignet und der
rucksack war schwerer und schwerer
brocken
die wirklichen unterschied machen aber
immer den menschen aus darunter ist
wichtig was wunder ist nicht drüber wie
im frühjahr kämpfen gelernt und heute
kämpfen
ob die uniform so als stark oder so als
schaue oder sp bs ge wer ist eigentlich
gleich gebirgstruppe benötigen jedoch
nicht nur spezielle ausrüstung ein
einsatz im hochgebirge unterscheidet
sich mitunter gravierend vom einsatz im
flachen gelände die schwierigkeiten oder
der unterschied zwischen einsatz im
gebirge und dem flachland ist
hauptsächlich die witterung
das heißt im gebirge kann es sehr sehr
schnell zwischen blues 30 grad minus 20
grad innerhalb einer stunde sein es kann
also der schlechte sommer raus sein und
innerhalb einer halben stunde nahm
halben meter schnee auf der blitzschlag
die witterungseinflüsse eben gestorben
und es wirkt das im gebirge viel stärker
auf der menschen ein
weil meistens möglichkeiten die
schutzhütte zwd bonn unterwegs sein
die versorgung ist ganz ganz wichtiger
punkt im gebirge und viele viele
schwieriger da meisten soll es von
herunten herz gebracht werden besonders
im kalten bürger gibt es ab einer
gewissen höhe karosser mehr das heißt es
muss das los die verpflegung und hierfür
braucht man als im gebirge spezielle
fahrzeuge wie mir selber zum beispiel
quads oder eben ski doos im winter oder
diese regel aus den 1
braucht der gebirgs soll dort um eben im
gebirge sie vernünftig versorgen zu
können so und zum kämpfen diese sorgen
sozusagen vergleich wie herunten aber
die witterung und das ganze ist hat viel
viel schwieriger
fünfzig jahre nach den ersten wochen als
ich denn das österreichische bundesheer
erinnert sich ein zeitzeuge 1967 zugs
kommandant eingesetzt an den damaligen
einsatz innovativer das stützpunkt das
können wir erinnern ist also noch im
waldgebiet gelegen und zwar ich vermute
dass der wirt wo dieses felswand hinauf
geht das dort hinten aber wie gesagt
noch im wald der stützpunkt war erwartet
ungefähr mit 25 oder 28 30 leuten und
wir sind also von dort aus die die
spähtrupps gegangen und haben von dort
auch in drei kontrollen kommen leute die
das einzige was einigermaßen erstaunt
war diese arbeiten und zu der war nicht
so schlecht aber wir haben also keine
ketten zelte kommt gott wir dort oben
versucht selten in der qualität sondern
nur staat oder irgendwas wenn er zum
steueraufkommen ist hat das ein
riesencoup und darum es ungefähr 600
plus
während dann später diese gruppen zelte
bekommen das war noch besser obwohl man
zuerst da kann hofen nichts trinken
wie man sieht diese bewusste der
gespräche aufkommen bin weil die
italiener zuerst muss sehr misstrauisch
der assistenzeinsatz war in keiner
hinsicht von großer bedeutung zum einen
wurde der politische zweck erreicht da
die gewaltaktionen in südtirol merklich
abnahmen
zum anderen konnte das bundes sehr
wertvolle erfahrungen im gebirge einsatz
zu sammeln
die besonderen herausforderungen dieses
einsatz bislang einfach nicht zuletzt im
hochgebirge es war einfach erforderlich
täglich im hochgebirge dienst zu
versehen die logistik zu bewältigen
die kommandanten worden mit ihren leuten
auf patrouille mussten wir
führungsaufgaben bewältigen
damit konnte sehr viel einsatz erfahren
im führungsbereich und in der logistik
gesammelt werden und es war damit auch
klar für das österreichische bundesheer
dass ein einsatz im gebirge durchaus
realistisch ist und das war also glaube
ich auch dann den gesamten kader klar
dass man in der gebirgs ausbildung etwas
tun muss noch dazu wo also doch
wesentliche grenz teile österreichs im
hochgebirge liegen